Ciao a tutti io sono Ivana ho 27 anni e
sono innamorata
sono innamorata del mio pianeta in
maniera irrazionale e viscerale
difficile esprimere un amore autentico
quando si è piccoli io sapevo solo di
volere bene al mio pianeta e quindi lo
usavo come sfondo per il cellulare o per
il computer
Difatti era l'unico strumento che avevo
a disposizione per dirmelo per il resto
a scuola superiore ho frequentato il
liceo delle scienze umane Perché tutto
sommato pure gli umani mi piacciono un
sacco
esistono tanti nuovi inizi Per fortuna è
il mio primo grande nuovo inizio è
avvenuto quando ho scoperto che esisteva
una facoltà chiamata geologia che
riguardava lo studio del pianeta Terra
ricordo perfettamente il mio sgomento
Cioè mi chiesi cioè esiste la
possibilità che io possa studiare il
pianeta Cioè che io possa lavorare cioè
che io venga pagata per studiare il
pianeta
What
e così mi scrissi
sfacelo
molto peggio di quanto credessi il mio
primo grande nuovo inizio
un turbine di bocciatura di rifiuti da
parte dei docenti di continui rimandi
alla mia incapacità di gestire
disciplina come la matematica la fisica
e la chimica un continuo sentirsi dire
non penso sia il percorso giusto per te
mi sentivo bloccata stagnante avrei
fatto di tutto per superare più
velocemente possibile gli esami ma ero
bloccata pure nelle intenzioni l'esame
di matematica per esempio avrei voluto
copiarlo ma non facevo niente
Così è iniziato il mio secondo nuovo
inizio perché ho scoperto che
all'interno del pianeta tutti i raggi
che trasportano energia scelgono sempre
il percorso più veloce per il principio
di Fermat e il percorso più veloce
coincide con le rocce più densa con
quelle più difficili da attraversare Io
ero andata lì per studiare il mio
pianeta e il mio pianeta mi aveva
incoraggiata
mi aveva detto se vuoi andare più
velocemente devi scegliere il percorso
più difficile
così ho iniziato a studiare matematica
ho iniziato dalla Roccia più densa
l'ho ripetuto otto volte l'esame per
superarlo alla nona
difficile restare serena quando tutti i
tuoi colleghi vanno velocissimi e tu
stai a meno di zero
Però intanto quella battaglia l'avevo
vinta
il mio terzo nuovo inizio è avvenuto
quando ho scoperto che le rocce
terrestri esseri apparentemente
insensinanti in realtà hanno una memoria
le rocce hanno memoria degli sforzi che
hanno sopportato
se sottoposte a quegli stessi sforzi non
si rompono più
è necessario uno sforzo sempre maggiore
per generare una rottura
ancora una volta un chiaro messaggio
dovevo avere memoria della mia battaglia
così non sarebbe stato un problema
sopportare gli stessi sforzi e così dopo
l'esame di matematica ho iniziato a dare
un esame dopo l'altro ad una velocità
che non pensavo mi appartenesse pezzo
per pezzo senza fare sconti lasciando
indietro i pezzi di un Ivana incapace e
inadeguata
non riuscivo a superare gli esami con
grandi voti però restavo una studentessa
mediocre non prendevo più di 25 lo
sapevo che il voto non era il modo per
valorizzarmi però sentivo che c'era
ancora una parte di me che volevo
trasformare
così ho scoperto che il calcare e il
marmo così apparentemente diversi hanno
la stessa origine
Ho scoperto che la grafite quindi il
materiale che usiamo per scrivere con la
matita e il diamante
hanno la stessa composizione chimica
il marmo è un calcare metamorfosato cioè
che ha sopportato pressioni e
temperature elevatissime e ha scelto di
sfruttare il dolore per diventare più
liscio luminoso e di qualità
il diamante è una grafite che però si
forma nel mantello terrestre quindi dove
la luce non batte dove fa caldo e si sta
stretti
forse era arrivata anche per me è
l'occasione di diventare
Diamante o marmo
in quel periodo stavo preparando una
materia astrusa la Geofisica applicata
che usa la matematica e la fisica per
studiare l'interno del pianeta senza
infastidirlo
e così mi sono Concessa la mia personale
metamorfosi superando l'esame di
Geofisica con 30 e lode
la mia prima lode in geofisica
Ivana
che aveva lasciato il calcare e la
grafite per dare forse spazio ad un
marmo è un diamante
è così è iniziato un processo in cui ho
superato tutti gli altri esami con voti
molto alti con il 30 questo famigerato
30 e mi sono laureata alla triennale
perfettamente in corso e con una tesi in
Geofisica applicata
quando mi sono iscritta alla magistrale
in Geofisica applicata ho scoperto che
il pianeta ha un obiettivo
e il suo obiettivo è raffreddarsi
come le sorelle e i fratelli Marte
Venere Mercurio il suo scopo è stare al
fresco e per realizzare il suo obiettivo
Sposta le masse fa le montagne crea gli
oceani si aiuta con i vulcani e con i
terremoti con qualche bum bum sparso qua
e là e sta riuscendo pian piano negli
anni a formare una crosta che gli
permetta di raffreddarsi Sebbene non
possa liberarsene
e così durante la magistrale Ho anche
scoperto che
quando il mio pianeta mette un'azione in
profondità questa azione ha una
conseguenza per circa 900 anni volevo
essere anch'io così incisiva nella mia
vita
e quindi nella magistrale ho superato
tutti gli esami con la lode vincendo un
premio di studio che mi ha permesso di
fare una tesi all'estero a Mainz di
laurearmi con 110 e lode e il plauso
della commissione di vincere un
dottorato in Geofisica per lo studio
della correlazione tra il campo
elettromagnetico terrestre e le onde
sismiche e ritrovarmi oggi a fare un Ted
talk sul mio pianeta
sono sicura che se fosse qui presente mi
avrebbe fatto un occhiolino
Io
sono
profondamente innamorata di un pianeta
così particolare perché non deve essere
facile essere grande
al caldo dover ruotare su se stesso e
attorno ad un'altra Stella tutti i
giorni tutto il giorno
farlo da sempre ed essere in grado di
ospitare così tanta vita
così tanta vita
la mia stima è enorme
oggi al mio pianeta che amo che apprezzo
voglio dire grazie per avermi
incoraggiata tantissime volte senza
saperlo
voglio dire grazie per ospitare me i
miei amici la mia famiglia e tutti noi
senza saperlo
e gli voglio dire grazie perché ho
scoperto che donna Voglio diventare
rotonda e profonda come te Grazie